[Musique]
voilà dans ça a toujours été un moyen
pour moi de m'exprimer en fait
différemment que par la parole
[Musique]
sarah pour moi c'est une des meilleures
millions en france elle a vraiment un
steve d'explosifs féminin et
charismatique
de quelque chose c'est pas pour la voir
la danse à la carrière ont changé ma vie
et l'autre par habib danseuse
professionnelle et lumbres et king de ma
ville d'origine à mumbai je vous
embarque avec moi dans mon quotidien de
madrid hier donc follow me
on est à mumbai on est là sur le toit
tout est un soutien avec la cimade
[Musique]
les battles c'est mon moteur de base est
jbeli dans ça depuis que j'ai 11 ans je
pense que pour les danseurs en de compte
donc ceux qui vraiment commencé dans la
rue c'est important et je pense qu'on a
tous commencé par des battles est devenu
très commercial et les gens apprennent à
danser dans des cours de danse où c'est
plus de la consommation qu'autre chose
là c'est différent mais après chacun vit
à sa façon la danse
[Musique]
la danse hip hop pas
une histoire c'est vraiment une culture
qui est vraiment belle je pense que
c'est important de savoir d'où ça vient
et savoir qui était là avant nous ça
n'est pas d'esprit c'est pas juste je
viens je danse hip hop de la semaine
oh
[Musique]
à des battles ça te fait kiffer de ouf
quand à des battles nuls parce que tu es
là tu as des gens qui ne vivent pas le
mont est ce qu'on aille réussite des
passagers sport dur il ya beaucoup
d'enjeu il ya des compétitions il ya
vingt mille dollars a gagné donc du coup
les gens ils sont là et voir un
entraînement ils sont aidés sont vénérés
diois cheveux tous les mickey rourke les
mecs assieds-toi traqué mais respirent
un coup kif
l'important pour moi c'est pas de gagner
quoi c'est d'abord son moment où toi
t'es content d'avoir été au max de sa
performance est fière de toi t'as kiffé
le moment et puis way brillé tout au
moment là donc bri tu peux perdre un
match peut être celui qu'on va retenir
pendant dix ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sarah pour moi elle est généreuse
énergique et captivante
quand elle a commencé vont y avait pas
énormément de bédié en train de moins
qu'aujourd'hui en tout cas et elle a
forcément remarqué l'histoire
la gagner des battles
cetto en tant que danseuse déjà femme
dans un milieu masculin qu'elle break
elle a réussi à faire sa plaque le blaze
il se fait avec les années il se fait
avec les performances et elle a prouvé
plus d'une fois en france et
internationale qu'elle avait le bagage
vous remportez des tiges ou faire ne
serait ce que des belles prestations
quand elle va danser je pense que
n'importe qui dans public en fait va
ressentir
c'est une des rares vigueur pour moi qui
me fait vraiment ressentir la musique
parce qu'elles vivent vraiment ce
qu'elle fait elle est vraie et sincère
je pense à danser et chanter à une
énergie folle allez comme cette année
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je parcours le monde entier
à travers ma passion donc la danse hip
hop je travaille en compagnie
des battles des compétitions et est ce
que vous voulez voir où tout a commencé
et bah allez je vous emmène avec moi
oui comme tout shadow city donc voilà
donc ici c'est
c'était mon squat à l'époque quand
j'avais
onze ans manuela ma partenaire clé un
partenaire alors d'aujourd'hui m'a
proposé de venir à l'entraînement
avec elle c'est comme ça que j'ai
commencé en fait mais
dans ces lapins fois où j'ai vraiment
essayé mes premiers pas de danse hip hop
donc voila c'était ici au niveau de
cette barrière j'étais le premier pas
que j'ai appris c'est un prise et donc
c'est une pause gelé entre guillemets
sur les mains est devenu du coup la
position c'est ça au mans mes parents
ils sont originaires d'alger vers l'est
sont arrivés en france pour avoir une
meilleure situation on va dire même au
niveau du travail et plus d'opportunités
du coup moi je suis né ici en fait mes
parents sont nés en algérie quand
j'étais jeune j'avais cette difficulté à
m'exprimer je parlais pas beaucoup de
moi de ce que je pouvais ressentir et du
coup là dedans ça me permettait de
d'extérioriser tout ça en fait toutes
les mauvaises énergies comme les
énergies positives aussi à la joie tout
sapin c'était vraiment pour moi un
échappatoire et aussi à un moment où je
me retrouve avec mes amis et j'ai
échangé avec eux et je m'amusais
personne n'avait l'intention d'être
quelqu'un dans ce milieu là c'était plus
on est là bien ou qui font danser notre
moment en fait ma famille ça a été pas
facile dans mes débuts de leur expliquer
que
bah c'est ce que j'ai envie de faire
parce que pour eux enfin la danse c'est
pas un métier
mon père ne sait pas du tout ce que je
fais jamais vu
quoi que ce soit de ce que je fais au
début c'était pas facile je me suis
battu et j'ai dû leur montrer que voilà
je peux en vivre et que et que ben voilà
c'est ça va au delà que
que d'une passion un sport où c'est
carrément une façon de vivre en fait et
pour moi leur soutien c'est de m'avoir
laissé faire mes parents
un jour décide de venir me voir en
représentation ou même
en compétition jusqu'à trop contente je
pense que je serai ému je pourrais me
verser la petite larmichette
[Musique]
nous allons aujourd'hui participé à la
première étape du battle donc un battle
c'est la confrontation
deux danseurs donc on a un one one dont
compétition solo ça consiste à danser en
opposés et on doit faire un questions
réponses
ce que promet 10 commence le deuxième
réponse ben les musiques on les connaît
pas ça on les connaît pas ce que c'est
du break vite et aussi des musiques hip
hop dont on a l'habitude d'entendre à
mai ces prix style c'est le dj qui mixe
et cesson tâche de nous ambiance et nous
on doit s'adapter à tout en fait
insolent qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de
danser à une musique qu'on s'est passé
avec la surprise chacun le face à face
on est là qui sont plutôt freestyle y en
a qui prépare vraiment tout de a à z
jusqu'au top rock et jusqu'aux prises
bon c'est bien beau de venir à red bull
mais bon il faut quand même se préparer
un minimum venez freestyle bas c'est un
risque et je ne prends pas le risque
donc j'ai vraiment travaillé des codes
qui fait que répéter répéter répéter
répéter répéter après un suivi sur la
musique et c'est de les amener
différemment à chaque fois tu essaie
vraiment de le danser différemment parce
que la musique tu dis des choses donc il
faut que tu le vivent différemment cette
compétition je le prends pas comme jean
roy
donc je défends sous mon nom j'ai envie
de montrer qui je suis
et j'ai la chance d'avoir mon propre
style et ma patte et du cou à partir du
moment que tu danses comme personne
parle un perdant
m
si c'est pour nous avec celui des 12 mai
[Applaudissements]
eh oui
[Musique]
9 comme ça la vie
oui
je garde tout ça
[Musique]
même score ça l'a tué l'impôt
exploit aussi
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
mais ce n'est pas tout
tu as they signal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le mood donc je suis après avoir perdu
la compétition au premier tour je suis
très déçu de moi-même en fait j'ai
travaillé pendant des mois et tout part
comme ça mais non après ça fait partie
du jeu j'accepte la décision du jury
perdre n'est pas forcément une mauvaise
chose déjà des fois c'est pas ton coeur
de briller de tout simplement donc
quelque peu trop mais tension tht échos
[Musique]
bobic c'est de la danse on n'en sera pas
toute notre life ce qui est notre corps
et va pas nous permettre de tourner sur
la tête trop dit oublie pas que avant
tout c'est un as en fait et qu'on doit
en fait respecter cet art qui fait
prendre le temps d'échanger avec les
jambes hammam et a compté le moment de
la compétition et a pas de problème
vazia dont mais oublie pas de prendre
plaisir de qui fait quand j'ai commencé
la danse j'étais une petite fille de
quartier qui traînait plus qu'autre
chose qu'avait pas spécialement
d'ambition dans la vie
et la danse m'a permis de vraiment me
diriger dans le droit chemin en fait
tout simplement que j'étais carrément
une meilleure personne dès mes premiers
pas de danse
[Musique]